welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by james
layton who is the founder and ceo of the
anderson james group
james started his recruitment career in
2005 where he actually started in tech
recruitment in london
since then he has worked for multiple
recruitment brands including michael
page and he took his recruitment career
into the property and construction
markets in 2015 he set up the anderson
james group who now have four key
divisions within the business executive
housing construction and consulting
the business is now nearly six years old
they have 16 people in the company with
ambitious growth plans and james's role
within the company now is all about the
strategic direction the growth and the
day-to-day management of
the group all together so james
it's a pleasure to finally have you on
the podmate
welcome thanks mate excited for this so
where we always like to start
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant
yeah well being an avid list now i knew
it was coming so we've done quite a lot
of work as a business on this with the
management team recently and then
bar the usual stock answers of work
ethic and
all the things that you hear like
resilience etc we broke it down into
three areas i think uh we look for
people that are inquisitive and curious
um we think it's a big part of what we
do
um we look for people that have got
quite obsessive personalities so that
are willing to sort of throw themselves
into things and really sort of double
down on being entrenched in their
marketplace so the way we test that
generally is like what have they been
obsessed with previously whether that
might be sport it might be a hobby it
might be something else like where have
they really gone the extra mile um i'm
sure we'll talk a little bit about that
and the other one's communication but
previously if you've asked me five years
ago i'd have said verbal communication
but we really test now written
communication really a big part of what
we do yeah so
we started to as part of our interview
process we've started to get candidates
to write a spec about themselves or or
an email to outline an introduction
because
you know i don't know what other markets
are like but our market specifically at
the moment is you know 50 50 i would say
verbal and and written yeah so you've
got to be able to write well and as you
know from a personal brand perspective
you've got to be able to to write good
content from time to time yeah
yeah that definitely was that was never
my strongest point to be fair writing i
think have you ever have you um you or
the team ever used at all heard of a
tool called grammarly
no but um it's interesting you say that
i've i've used it personally but the
team don't use it but just to make sure
if i'm sending out anything important i
just run it through that tool and make
sure it's exactly yeah yeah because
that's what i mean like relying on a
human person to always make sure it's
accurate there's going to be things that
slip through and i remember i actually
did a similar thing my boss got me to do
something when i joined his recruitment
business and um i was actually that bad
at sort of writing i didn't have that
enough confidence i actually i paid
someone to do my cb
did you yeah
like 780 quid and i was like what yeah
why not you know i mean obviously i just
flagged it as was like yeah i did this
evie did it all that so yeah yeah like
fair but i get the written thing but i
think there's definitely tools that
people should use that can help support
there's going to be key things you're
going to be looking for are they
actually capable of putting things
together
100 yeah so
obviously
been in the recruitment game for a while
a lot to uncover but obviously i want to
really focus on the sort of aj journey
so far since 2015 right but let's just
touch on james layton early days being
an employee a recruiter and a few
different recruitment brands so i didn't
actually realize that when obviously i
prepared for this
i thought he was always like in the
manchester way but obviously started in
london
right
in like classic tech recruitment like
how
like when you think about
early days of recruitment for you
like what what comes up for you how
like what what was difficult like how
yeah how do you see the past it's
interesting um i moved to london on my
own uh as a young 20 something year old
chap um
and i got into a bit of trouble back
home in terms of i was from burnley
originally there's not a lot of in terms
of industry there so i knew i had to
move out of that area to try and
progress my career and i went down to
london and did i met a rec to wreck at
the time i didn't know they were wrecked
right i met director rec and he said
look recruitment would be great for you
you need to do this and i remember
getting off the tube once in bank as
like
young man and thinking
[ __ ] hell this place is insane like
everyone's got suits ties all that sort
of stuff and i went to like five
interviews and ended up joining portland
resourcing but i had no understanding of
what recruitment was and they put me
into
sap tech
in germany which was uh which was an
interesting and interesting burnley lad
taken over the sap german market base
yeah yeah honestly mate you couldn't
[ __ ] write it to be fair
they just give me like a zing license
and said this is at the time now i
realize it's like a linkedin platform
and you just need to connect with all
these german sap professionals and try
and place them into into global
businesses and to be fair
it was a massive introduction to the
sector because 90 of the people didn't
want to speak english to you so you were
just trying to get through gatekeepers
in english and it was wow it was an
interesting period i mean yeah obviously
you were there for like nearly four
years
so like like surely like what that must
have been a bit of a roller coaster no
like surely that was really difficult
there's tools like those translation
tools even back then and so you put your
emails through translation tools you try
and make an effort with the
german culture and the good thing about
um german sap was that they're really
really disciplined in the way that they
work so if you do get a relationship in
that area and a lot of these businesses
you know we were working with like
global companies coca-cola you know the
big big businesses a lot of them spoke
english yeah sure the interesting thing
is if they didn't want to talk to you
clearly their english got worse and
worse and worse as the conversation went
on so it was easy to get pride in that
world but i think
when i started out in that journey like
my my journey was slightly different in
the fact i had to make it work i was
living in london i had no money i was
like i'm gonna make commission here to
just even get on the tube every day so
yeah you're just like
you've got you burned the boats i'm sure
you've heard that phrase before pretty
much yeah yeah yeah we burnt the box
there was no other option other than to
make it success and to be fair it was a
tough 12 months you know it was really
tough but
in some ways i always say this to my
guys as well it's like
it's sometimes better when you don't
know i you just throw yourself into it
and it's the normality for you at that
time um looking back now if someone said
go and do german sap i'd rather not um
but
yeah at that point in time
yeah yeah so i guess interested best
best piece of advice you got early on do
you think that helped you
well as we just said be fearless you
know
the thing that
we've started to see and our trainings
definitely got better over the last five
or six years but is that we really look
for that now in a person like will they
throw themselves into the into
situations that are difficult and push
themselves out of comfort zone and i
think i've always been pretty good at
that in terms of just totally throwing
myself out of my comfort zone and seeing
what happens and if i hadn't done that
in that situation
i think the result would have been very
different it was a high turnover company
that i worked for in the sense that it
was really hard international markets
weren't easy back then
i think a lot more companies have gone
overseas now yeah and it's it's
definitely become
more the done thing back then it was
like it was genuinely foreign excuse the
pun yeah yeah fair okay love that so
talk to me about how did you then
obviously go from obviously i guess i'm
just curious on like
how you dealt with transitioning markets
right interested that because obviously
some people obviously will think about
that in their career or be quite worried
about that so how did you then end up
going from that sort of world to then
obviously by the time what he was in
michael page or was it a hr go
recruitment was already in the more
property space
yeah it's it's interesting i did two
tech companies so i worked for a
business that at the time were called
chapman black i think they changed their
brand a couple of times but um i moved
from portland resource into a business
called chapman black more lately
and worked for a guy called ezra chapman
he was pretty inspirational and someone
that really liked drove me into a
different part of my career
and i think through seeing people change
markets there quite often i thought look
i can do any market here and an
opportunity just a rose to
join
hr goal to work on one account it was
like a big account management job and i
thought i fancy that and so
i tried it at the time i didn't see the
relevance of me moving markets i just
thought it's recruitment yeah you can do
that
yeah yeah i can do that but obviously
now when people started to niche markets
a lot more i think it's a lot harder for
people to move between different markets
you're starting again almost so that's
the perception but we've got a guy who's
start with those uh
rick who you've met and
you know
insurance finance yeah risk insurance
finance financial services and he is
absolutely smashing it's 12 months in so
it can be done with a little bit of
strategy combined with a bit of elbow
grease to be honest yeah well let's just
let's just pull back the onion a bit on
this thing because i think it's useful
for people
i think obviously i'm sure obviously
we're talking offline like how difficult
it is to hire for your business at the
moment but i guess any advice for anyone
that
like is maybe thinking you know what i
want to stay in recruitment but i
actually like the idea of potentially
changing markets or i'm concerned about
changing markets like what
what what advice would you give me if
i'm making that transition or
considering it
yeah
the advice i would give is that you know
i i'm always a big fan of just follow
you go and and i honestly think that i t
and tech recruitment didn't necessarily
suit me look i did all right i build
well
but it wasn't a real skill set match for
what i've done what i've now gone on to
do and
i felt that the personality driven
markets were better for me and that's
why i ended up transitioning to property
and construction i think if someone's
looking to to move markets
you know you've got to trust the process
and you've got to trust that i'm a good
recruiter and a good recruiter can
recruit in any market i say to my guys
all the time like we've got to make
ourselves
the very very best at what we do and
that we can find candidates in any
corner of the world in any sector in any
market and if someone asks you for a i
don't know russian astronaut you should
be able to map out that world who has
the candidates that you can target who
are the clients that would recruit those
types of roles and you should be able to
build a market relatively quickly
the problem is generally people
get into a bit of a comfort zone around
the market that they're in and think
it's too scary to go and do the the
other markets out there
but my my understanding of that and my
advice for anyone trying to thinking
about moving markets would be
you've got to just throw yourself into
these things and you know
given the technology change recently
what we've found has been a big big help
for us is that we've been able to expand
geographies quite seamlessly and we've
been able to do 30 40 50 minute
check-ins with clients and have
face-to-face meetings or online which
would have usually been in person and so
you can grow your market we we've got a
guy that's just joined us to do exact
search he's done 75 meetings in his
first three months
but you couldn't do that
yeah you couldn't have done that
face-to-face so
you know the playing field has been
leveled to change markets if ever
someone was going to move markets now's
the time because
you know it's quite saturated out there
from a recruitment perspective
especially in the uk market
but
the technology is there to support you
being able to break into these customers
a lot easier and build relationships
yeah great point yeah i think
take to run that off it's just like yeah
trust trust that you can do recruitment
trust trust the process as you said back
yourself on that and then it's like like
you said back to what you're looking for
in the sort of people that early on in
their careers like throw yourself into
it and learn listen i guess also there's
i just always hear it's just good advice
of like let people know that like look
hey i am building up this market this is
the journey on i'm bringing these people
on that journey because people are happy
to help
right
um so okay nice i like that so obviously
then let's just fast forward a bit then
but keen to to ask you just interested
how so um
my so hr go then was that like sort of
corporate
vibes yeah so they're they're a big like
branch mentality recruiter so they do a
lot of like driving industrial other
recruitment and they managed to win like
a huge property and construction account
where they'd recruit all their
recruitment for 10th and perm
right and obviously they had no one in
their business that did it and so they
recruited myself as a almost an internal
external recruiter like an on-site
recruiting business so i just spent all
of my life although i worked for hr goal
working for one business as their
internal recruitment company oh man um
and it was like that's a really good
experience there
the best experience
yeah
and it's a bit of advice that i i've
given to people previously is you know
there used to be a stigma around doing
internal recruitment and these rpo type
accounts but actually
i honestly think i've learned more of
being an internal recruiter for the
period i was trying to get rid of my
restricted covenants whilst leaving
michael page than
any of the external recruitment agency
experience i've had because you
understand about business the way it
takes the way that people make the
decisions why they make the decisions
they make and also the inner workings of
how a talent strategy and a hr strategy
work
let's just talk about this for a second
and then we'll go into the aj story
because i think i think it's useful and
i'm sure i don't i don't know if you do
a bit of this i know that when obviously
when because i know um quite a bit about
your business i know that you have
different services right but i don't
know if you even notice more and more
recruitment businesses like offering
this sort of talent partner solution
like you know i'm sure you've seen that
where it's like james layton
partners with x company via anderson
james do you know what i mean
so i feel like more and more
agency recruiters one of the solutions
or problems they're trying to fix is the
things that you're just talking about
the inner workings the actual hr
problems the talent strategy problem all
of that
so i guess thinking about this for a
second
from your experience what are some of
the things i guess
people assume about being in that world
an internal recruiter whatever you want
to call it that probably people get
wrong
because i think it's easy for an agency
side to go oh james the talent manager
for yeah wilmot dixon is he's slow he
never gets back to me all he cares about
is pleasing the people i don't know do
you know what i mean like we can make
those assumptions can't we in agency so
like what are some of the assumptions
that you think people get wrong a lot of
the time because you've been in that
seat
um
there's a couple of points on that and
things that i think about one is that
it's a harder job than anyone will ever
imagine because you get pulled from
pulitzer post internally as well as
externally so you've got a lot of
stakeholders to manage i think
the the challenge from a recruiter
perspective is if you saw what went on
inside some of these big plc businesses
you know wilma dixon were a billion
pound company
and the just volume of sheer volume of
recruitment that they deal with on a
daily basis is crazy when i went there
they were one of my biggest clients at
michael page and i went there as their
internal recruiter and i thought
honestly i was thinking i've honestly
got this place tied up i do all their
recruitment
and you get inside and realize wow my
tiny tiny percentage that i used to
build in this business there's thousands
of recruiters making two three four
hundred k out of them and i'm like
you honestly just think from a
perception and it's something that i
tell my guys all the time is like don't
ever get assumed that you know
everything about business because
clearly when i've gone internally you're
like wow i am small fry in this place
like in terms of what i've done for them
um but the external appearance or what i
thought when i was at my page was that
we've got this sewn up we're doing all
their recruitment there's no
infiltration there's no leakage to other
agencies
that was ridiculous i was like number 20
in the list of agencies that work with
them that's nuts
and i think yeah i think people can
that's where i think people go wrong
when it comes to like expanding accounts
right that they can assume like like you
just said yeah i've got this this
client's suite
in the palm of my hand
does a lot of their business but maybe
thinking back you could have probably
asked a few more questions or been a bit
more curious maybe to find out and
realize actually
i'm only doing a sliver of what i could
be doing or what my why did you be doing
100 and it's that classic isn't it
mapping out a market properly and when
someone's giving you roles asking that
one further question to say well
what else is happening in your business
who else can i connect with who else can
i speak to and generally because you're
doing well with one contact so you can
sometimes get a little bit lazy around
that and think well we're doing really
well let's just carry on as we are yeah
yeah that's really interesting any other
any other headaches that people may be
addressing one a common one that i've
heard i don't know what your experience
was was that whole like internal
stakeholder management like we've we've
had a few agencies recently joined
recruitment mentors who their whole
model is that talent partner model and
one of the areas that they
want sort to develop or advice on or
hear how other people dealing with it is
that internal talent is that internal
stakeholder management i think that's a
completely different ball game and that
i feel like yeah so we do outsource
stuff here and it makes up nearly half
of our business at the moment and it is
totally outsourced recruitment so we're
basically act as the internal
recruitment function of a business okay
but when i was at wilma dixon and taking
the knowledge from that what you realize
is that recruitment and you've always
got to remember this recruitment makes
up about one percent of someone's job
generally at the board level anyway and
so
they just want that headache taken away
from them and you've got to find ways to
make that as seamless as possible for
the end user and also put them at the
epicenter of the problem so actually
think well
that person hasn't got time to deal with
me i need to do all the due diligence
and everything that i need to do within
this process to make it smooth for them
and if you do that generally that the
people that did the best with me from an
agency perspective were always the ones
that didn't keep hounding you didn't
keep hustling you didn't expect you
listened to what you asked you know i'm
the amount of times i've said someone
can you just stop sending spec emails in
because we just don't look at them
and five minutes later you'd get another
one and from an internal perspective
you'd think well that's fine like you
carry on but it's just proves to me that
you can't listen it's nothing to do with
the power of the situation it's just you
can't listen and therefore yeah i'll
give you a brief are you going to even
listen to that is it just going to be
send cvs willy-nilly so i think quality
is everything and when you work in an
internal recruiter
the scale of quality
from agency to agency is vast you know
from the really poor quality agencies
right through to the very good ones
the the actual gulf of quality is crazy
to watch from the internal perspective
interesting so let's let's unpack this
your your business journey then so far
right because i know there's been ups
and downs
and i feel like obviously yeah obviously
i've known you for a little while now i
do feel like
um
like i do feel like whenever i've spoken
to you recently you just seem really
positive about what the future looks
like and is it fair to say maybe you
might have turned a bit of a corner
really in terms of like
what's going on and how does it think
about this yeah before i came on today i
was thinking about this and
and i was thinking you know what
where should i position the journey and
i think the best way for me to do that
is to be candid in the sense that we
didn't take an investment when we
started and i really thought about it
was as i was setting up we really
thought of an investment i spoke to
actually ezra chapman black sports a few
other like angel investors and we
decided not to take investment and i'm
really pleased that we didn't take
investment and for those people that are
out there thinking about setting up
their own recruitment companies
whilst everyone's got different
circumstances if you can avoid
investment i'd avoid investment and the
only reason i'm saying that is because
i've quite enjoyed the struggle as well
as the joys and the successes that we've
had of
how does finance work how does it work
how does the back office work how do we
send invoices out and actually creating
that infrastructure over the five or six
years whilst it's been a pain in the ass
it has been a really really really good
journey to go through yeah because i
think it's really rounded my business
acumen for a start and secondly
you understand each each facet of your
business from day one you have to you've
got no choice you've got this yourself
i'm sure um but we didn't take
investment and obviously cash flow was a
massive problem and i think in the early
days we hired someone in month three i
hired steph who'd worked for me for a
long time at my page and we hired her
after three months and
whilst looking back it's the best thing
i ever did hiring steph it's also
ridiculous to think we hired someone
when they didn't even
well what gave you that what gave you
that fearlessness then to do that
yeah yeah it probably was and it's
probably a bit of naivety but it was
just i always wanted to grow a business
and i spent three years of our journey
thinking headcount was the thing that we
would measure our success on
as you get into the fourth fifth sixth
seventh eighth year i'm sure head count
becomes irrelevant and business
performance becomes more important and
how you're performing from a
profitability perspective becomes more
important but in the early days like i
honestly just used to be like it's the
age old isn't it you go to a bar and you
meet an old man you used to work with an
equipment like how many heads are you
know it's the first question yeah why
was you why was you caught up on that do
you think of four yeah
i think yeah i think yeah like we got
told from
most of the people um when i was about
to set up from the previous business
that it'll never work and you've got no
chance you'll be back here in two years
and that negativity and that
ironically that negativity's really
driven me so i'm going to appreciate
those people yeah yeah absolutely thank
you to those people but it also creates
a bit of an ego which i've managed to
rub off over the years but in the first
two years it was like we can take on the
world
we'll hire loads of people and it's not
as easy as it looks yeah fair enough
so let's unpack this a bit then
so obviously early on so you started
with one other person right
yeah decided not to take investment
hired obviously someone um really early
on
i guess like hindsight's a great thing
right
like what what are some of the things
that we would do differently do we think
if you were to to start over that's what
people
i guess want to learn from we'll find
out know what you know now how would you
approach things differently do you think
i think i think the number one thing
that i would do is build up if you've
not taken investment if you take an
investment you should know what your
growth plan looks like and the triggers
for that growth plan if you are going
down an organic route which is what we
chose you
need to think about everyone talks about
business plans i never made one i've got
one now but i didn't have one back then
and i still wouldn't have one now
because the fluidity is very important
at that stage but if i was to look at
sort of when i would hire
i would build up the bank account i
would build up the
the amount of money that we had to play
with and i'd spend 12 months just
billing and then focus on all the other
things first
i suppose what you end up doing is you
try and create a business that's fully
functional that's plc that's
got everything it needs in the first
year when you should just focus on doing
the job and and billing and making some
money and putting it in the bank and
then understanding what you've got to
play with before you start making hires
whereas
you know we were month four already
starting to think of how we're going to
make payroll this month
because we put ourselves in such a tight
spot from a financial perspective
because we had to build to just make
payroll and you know we weren't in a
position financially where or i wasn't
anywhere where i couldn't have been paid
for the first 12 months so i hadn't
given myself a buffer it's burned the
bulks right that's the only mentality no
money in the bank nothing going on we
have to build from day one to make this
work and and what we did was we just
sold clients consultancy services we
brought job descriptions we honestly
just did whatever we had to do to make
things work in the early days and i
spent a lot of that first six to 12
months pitching clients for new ideas
and trying to get some partnership stuff
going and
it was really successful but it was
really stressful because we put
ourselves under pressure with hires from
month three yeah so like month three
month five month six we're already
hiring people
and i honestly think that that's
prevented us from growing long term
because we've had to redo a lot of stuff
in year three four five now to give us
that platform
um
and so so my advice to anyone would be
build up your cash reserves make sure
you've got a good runway for someone i
generally look at a six month eight
month runway now of overhead costs in
the bank
so then provide a contributing at all
basically like they've got six to eight
months
yeah yeah yeah and and from a cash
perspective we always have 12 months
worth of all thread at the bank for our
whole business to make sure that
whatever happens we've got 12 months if
we didn't bill another penny now we'd
have 12 months of runway and that's
a position you build up all the time
you're not going to get that in the
first two or three years but
the one thing is is to make sure that
you have that runway of cash the second
thing is partner with the right clients
and i think people lose sight of that
massively
so
we partnered with anyone that would work
with us in some cases and we would just
do whatever we needed to do to make make
revenue in the first instance and
there's bad clients and good clients
right
bad pound good pound as i call it with
the team and actually
partner with businesses that share your
values and partner with businesses that
generally are nice to work for because
what we didn't realize is we did loads
of revenue people in the first year they
wouldn't pay us we couldn't get all of
them they didn't like working with you
know it was it was a forced relationship
because
we were chasing revenue they were just
trying to get a quick service and it it
was a bit in some cases really good from
the partnership stuff we did in some
cases the one spot work that we did with
clients ended up in tears every time
really so i was going to ask you like so
so how would you describe bad pounding
because i think that i think right now
i'm sure you agree a lot of a lot of
recruiters could fall into the trap of
being busy fools and there's loads of
live jobs at the moment and like you
said working working bad pound jobs are
like you said
yeah clients you enjoy working with
clients that actually pay you like what
other things could contribute to that
you think so i mean we do this in
training a lot with the guys but
just having good quality jobs you know
like we were working with businesses
that we knew had bad reputations at
times that we knew was struggling
financially that wanted to drive our
rates down to lower than we were
prepared to work at
the
you know when someone drops your service
fee or someone wants to drop a
recruitment fee at this stage in this
market right here right now
you've got to ask yourself
why is that and and what level of
service are they looking for because for
me
learning from the first year
we just was hanging on to any fee and
anything that we could get out of but we
were working multi-contingent jobs at
times we were working stuff with clients
that we knew hadn't got a great
reputation
and it does nothing for your reputation
to work with businesses like that so you
know after six months of doing that we
were just like right we're just gonna
work business as we like and we just
took a no [ __ ] policy really right
you're not going to work with people
that we don't want to work with
and
it's the best thing we ever did because
if i fast forward to months 6 to 12 and
onwards we just work with three or four
really good businesses we've got a
really good relationship and they're
still our biggest customers of today so
the ones that we created in the first 12
months are still our biggest customers
now
um and then let's let's just describe
really quickly because everyone this is
subjected right but i think it's just
good to hear different people's point of
view so just to make this really clear
how would you describe
a good client a committed client of
interest what other things do we want to
look for right now that
could give us that confidence
i mean i'd probably give you a different
answer 12 months ago but the market is
so busy at the moment that i think a
good client has to be
mutually invested in the relationship
and i talk about this as like shared
equity in the process so
if
they aren't showing the signs of
commitment they need to to recruit the
right person typically those things fall
down at the end of the process so you
know if i look at our work at the moment
we're probably somewhere in the region
of 65 70 retained at the moment as a
business
because
and
you know i know what people will say
yeah but at your level recruitment
because typically our work is 60k plus
and people will say that that's an easy
market to retain we've also started
doing 50 40k rolls retained as well
because
if someone wants to recruit someone and
i just think of this from my own
perspective i retain a business in
manchester that does all of our
recruitment for us and
no problem if i'm going to hire someone
then it's the same fee it's just
structured in a slightly different way
that gives everyone equitable value in
the process um
so we're just starting to to test that
commitment through pitching a retainer
now
i was always taught at sort of
businesses i've worked previously like
pitch the top service that you offer
because the only way that that can go is
that they'll come down a level so we've
always pitched retained as a model to
every role
and if that doesn't quite work out well
you'll end up with an exclusive job if
you retur if you pitch multi-contingent
recruitment
you're unlikely for the client to turn
around and say he's a retainer congrats
so shared equity in the process so these
clients
invested in the process coming back to
you when you agree things and if if this
client seems a bit disengaged early on
there's a good chance that
yeah that things probably aren't going
to go to plan
to the end and this might be a job that
could actually hoover up a lot of my
time which isn't going to be
good yeah we do it we do a lot of tests
in our business i don't know if other
companies do this but certainly we test
that commitment with a new relationship
all the time so we'll set some
pre-agreed agreed dates
we'll also send a test tv just to make
sure that we get feedback on that tv
rather than go out and do
two weeks worth of work which you're
typically going to do on a roll
send a shortlist and then realize that
the client's not coming back to you
we'll send a quick cv in the first two
or three day window and say can you just
give us some feedback on this if they
never respond or we don't get any
feedback we understand then that they're
not committed and we'll pull the plug on
the browser
and that i love that
let's talk about now quickly then i know
we're getting practically but i think
it's really useful right now
like you just said pull the pug on the
pull the um plug on the process
how do we go about doing that because i
feel like i'm sure you've seen in your
team it's quite hard to say no right or
quite hard to
say yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure this
is quite working out james like what how
do we communicate that
and well
there's two ways so we send the test cv
we should have pre-agreed that on a call
that actually we're gonna probably send
you a couple of options to make sure
we're on the right lines with the search
etc
we'll wait for you to come back until we
until we start search so if you don't
get that feedback in the time frame that
you've agreed with the client you don't
really have a further action there it's
just until you come back to us we're not
starting on this role
and and generally it's like
the thing that i think we're doing a lot
of at the moment is is taking it away
from customers and saying look it seems
to me that you're not quite committed to
this process that's fine like and by all
means we want to support you long term
however right here right now
it looks like you're not quite ready for
this so when you are please do come back
to us and you'll either get two
responses there well we are ready you
need to crack on or
yeah fair enough actually thanks for
giving us the candid feedback we'll come
back to you when we're ready to make a
start on this yeah i love that that's
great um okay and it happens all the
time we had one today which is a real
live example of better retainer proposal
out for three or four rolls we thought
it was nailed on the client thought it
was nailed on they pulled it because the
funding wasn't available until three
weeks time no problem
how that would have worked on a
contingent basis though is that we'd
done all the work and then they'd
applaud the plug when we'd done all the
work so yeah i think recruiters of today
and the modern age recruiter should be
valuing their time more than ever before
and if and if they're not
unfortunately there's going to be a lot
of rabbit holes you go down that have no
success and
that's not good for candidates it's not
good for clients it's not good for
consultants it's not good for anyone in
the process if everyone's wasting time
yeah for sure
all right so we've spoken quite a lot
about retained i'm keen to like just dig
a bit more into that but before we do
let's just talk about i guess let's just
zoom in a bit on like the last maybe
like two years or so let's just
like because i feel like yeah i'm
interested to
so how would you how would you describe
the business
before like as you were going into like
coved would you say like how do you
describe the business and then let's
talk about some of the things that
you've learned
changed that you feel have had a because
yeah
describe the business was before we went
into clovid
before corbin to be honest we i had a
bit of um
me and my business partner then and
we'll come back to that but me and my
business partner then we're just having
a bit of a lull at that stage we were
growing so we've grown 25 30 percent
year on year which has been fine and
it's been good like
revenue
revenue revenue profit
head count slightly over that and i
think
at that stage before covert even
happened we were just having i remember
the christmas before covered happened we
were like hmm
are we feeling this where are we at what
are we thinking and we never had a plan
so it's it's like i heard on another
podcast the other day you know for me it
was like we're climbing everest and we
didn't really know what we were trying
to achieve so we got to the top of it
and it was like well that's a totally
tough place to be when you've got these
people that you're responsible for yeah
and you and you've got to put a good
face on for people and i think the one
thing that um we've always been is
really transparent really open with
people but it just felt like it was
lacking a bit of purpose at one point
and i was burnt out we'd work really
hard we hadn't taken many breaks in that
period to get the business off the
ground and actually
covered was
was a blessing for us other than the the
obviously
horrible health things that have
happened in the businesses and stuff and
some of my friends have got hospitality
recruitment businesses so i i really did
feel for them in that period but for us
it was a real line in the sun what we're
doing next and as we entered that period
me and my business partner decided that
we were going to part ways because
i think what was happening is that we
were pulling each other in other
directions so i was trying to pull to
grow the business he was trying to pull
to make it more lifestyle and
it sort of put us in a bit of a lull
period for the year that i talked about
and
i think it was the right decision to say
well if you want a lifestyle business
you can't do that like we both value
each other's input to what we've done to
this point but i want to go and scale
and at that point we're about eight
heads nine heads and
it was like
take someone on wait for them to bed in
there was no real strategy to what we
were trying to achieve
and
it was just
felt a little bit like going through the
motions for the last 12 months so when
we when we separated obviously covered
hit and it was like right we're in a
world of pain here it's not a great time
we took a brave decision as did andy at
the time
and he's gone on to do great things and
we've accelerated everything in our
business since that point in the sense
that it was probably what we needed for
a catalyst to go right what are we
trying to achieve yeah plan together
and cover give me like a reset but i
don't know how other people feel but it
gave me a month where i couldn't do
anything so i just reset wrote a
business plan got all my ideas down i
thought about how we were going to risk
what i thought was going to be rescue
the business at the time because
i thought we were gonna i thought we're
gonna go pop at one point because you're
just thinking well if this market
doesn't come back for another 12 18
months how are people going to survive
um
but actually our market came back really
quick we were really fortunate our key
customers from the early years really
bailed us out and and we've done really
well ever since but
we're now on a proper plan proper budget
proper financial plan
we invested in the non-executive
director he put us on the right
right path um yeah and i
i spent the fortune like i i doubled
down on every single part of our
business technology we bought loads of
new systems we bought loads of things
that we would upskill the guys
we did lock down training sessions twice
a week with the guys so that they just
kept fresh while they were on furlough
for a couple of months and
it's the best decision i ever made like
it was risky at the time but it was
either we double down now and we go for
it
or we just accept we're going to be this
eight nine ten head business
and it wasn't something
right thanks for sharing that
i think i think a lot of people will
relate to that so few things on unpack
here
thinking about that period where
obviously yeah ended up being a bit of a
reset for you what were some of the like
the important questions that you asked
yourself because i think like a lot of
this sort of stuff can come from great
questions
so like these are questions that people
listen to this could start because i
think that's such a horrible position to
be in isn't it when it's your business
and you like it i actually don't know if
i actually like
the the business and what we've created
here
so like what what questions did you ask
yourself which helps you start realizing
what you wanted things to be yeah well
luckily we had a great i had a great
relationship with andy so we we we did a
lot of this together uh in the first
instance and then i separated out my
thoughts but the thing that i didn't
have at that time was a purpose like
where we're heading here is it just the
case if we just slowly but surely
trickle away and make this business into
what it is
because it just it never felt like it
could grow past eight nine heads it felt
like it was stuck at that level and um
but it was still in a weird way tied me
down it was still i had to be in the
office every day i had to be there for
the guys i had to make sure that you
know we had enough revenue coming in it
was almost like stuck between a
lifestyle business and a growth business
and so the questions i asked myself were
am i enjoying this what's my purpose and
what's the purpose of our business what
we're trying to achieve and where is
where's it heading like what do we want
to get out of it and
what i realized is that
and the big learning for me in that
whole period was
twofold one was you need to have a plan
of what you want to get out of it but
you've also got to accept that you can't
just
drive everything towards an event there
can't just be one target and it can't
move and it can't be fluid because it's
like that everest means i just said like
you're climbing up everest and you don't
actually know what you're trying to
achieve at the end um
so you need a bit of a plan and a bit of
a structure in your thoughts around what
you want to achieve but actually it's
got to be fluid so that you're enjoying
the journey not just enjoying the
destination yes about the process yeah
and like i wasn't enjoying the journey i
was hating the journey and and
i had to be quite honest with myself why
am i hating the journey and it and it
was generally i've
not enjoyed the person that i turned
into and i've not enjoyed the business
that we created at that particular
moment in time and it wasn't
toxic and it was fine and everyone in
our team will have not known what i was
going through mentally at that stage but
it was just
they were happy but i wasn't i was sat
there thinking this is not for me and
i employed a non-executive director i
got a personal coach we've got a
business coach and actually over that
period of time i've really really like
discovered what i want to get out of
this i love that from us so yeah it's
been good would you mind sharing um
like you have to go into like numbers
and everything but like i think
sometimes people think okay well i'm
going to sit down and think about
what the business is going to be turning
over revenue wise what all that so like
what are some of the i know you said it
has to be fluid and i really like that
so obviously it has to be ever ever
changing but you have to have some sort
of like north star that you're aiming
towards
what what are some of the things that
you're aiming towards in terms of is it
revenue is it head count goals what are
some of the cool things yeah
there's a couple of yeah there's a
couple bits um financial yep we brought
a business plan financially that was the
first point and that was the staple diet
of
we needed the financials to support the
growth plan that we wanted to achieve so
i made a decision that it was going to
be a growth business and i made a
decision that i was going to take less
money i was going to take less profit
out of the business and i was going to
invest a lot more okay and in order to
do that we had to get the numbers to
where we needed to get them so at that
stage so if i go 2019 our year today it
was about 700k or something in that
world 715 nfi which is which is not
great for a three-year-old business um
but
since that you know we decided that last
year we wanted to beat that which we did
and then this year it's we're on a
financial business plan which is
1.5 million nfi
2 million nfr
2.5 million nfi that will end up landing
as a million pound net profit is the
month okay and and the reason for that
was we realized to keep our staff happy
and we broke into three key principles
uh some a bit corny but like
we worked out what does our business
want to achieve we want to be
do right by people which we've always
done small things big things everything
but if we're going to do right by our
staff what does that mean well you've
got to be paid well the commission's
going to be great which always has been
here we've got to give them training and
development progression plans and a
roadmap to success what their success
looks like and
we didn't have that because clearly a
roadmap to success means we need growth
because we can't afford people manager
roles and director roles and all the
other things if we don't grow
so
we needed to do that the second thing
was around like quality not quantity
right clients right people right staff
right processes right infrastructure and
so we built that out as a plan and the
third thing was like atomic habits or
effective habits of just
what the day-to-day processes look like
and making sure that they're ingrained
in our culture standards yeah i love
that
that's awesome
and i have to ask you i'm going to ask
you about you and then that's a common
question again i know we've spoken about
things like that in the past
um
investment in like
another common question i get like in in
that decision of like right instead of
taking i'm gonna be investing more
investing more to grow more what what
like tools tech and stuff have you
invested in that has had a real impact
on your business well
the first thing that manly execs said to
me when we started on our first call was
two things you don't change in this this
industry one is the commission structure
two is your technology system so your
crm
so the first two things that i did was i
changed my crm system and i increased my
commission structure so
um
so obviously good at taking feedback but
um
we uh implemented vincerie um
right in the heater lockdown we decided
that it was the right time the old
system that we use with clunky i'm a
real real real believer of ventura as a
system and if i was i must have
recommended 20 people to vinceri over
the years because
i think they're going to change the game
um and i can say that wholeheartedly
having used bull horn and another
product i can say that venturi is number
one in that world for a growing
recruitment business because it's it's
intuitive it's got intelligence suites
it's got everything that you probably
need
to yeah it's a whole operating system
not just a crm is it it's a whole point
yes
it's brill and they're brilliant like
you know um eloise and the team they're
they're great and they're always there
if you need them for anything so any
other tools that you've invested in that
are sort of yeah non-negotiable for you
yeah we we got told by our clients that
odd draw would never work or video
technology would never work and and i
can wholeheartedly say that they all
love video technology now in their
recruitment process and save them time
um so that's been good we use source
breaker which has been a game changer
for our delivery function so the
outsource part of our business because
it just saves them hours and hours each
day yeah um
and the latest one that we've used we're
just about to launch new york well we
have launched new york but soft launch
at this stage so by the time the podcast
comes out it should be out there
um
zoom in for one of the best yeah
america in there
yeah yeah that's right that does nicely
yes you can get obviously contact
details and customer information and
obviously uk versus that popular ones
are like yeah lusher you hear a lot
you've got things like lead iq seem
seamless ai a few things yeah absolutely
no brainer people aren't looking at
these tools by the way
yeah yeah well the zoom import thing as
well they've just bought a business in
the uh europe which means that they're
downloading thousands and thousands of
records but in america if you're going
into america without zooming for
yeah and then i mean it well it's just i
think it must level the playing field
with any big global business that are
out there already because yeah it's a
show there's not a contact on there
that's not got mobile number email
address contact details it is insane
yeah okay so but before we finish i just
want to make sure we sort of made this
crystal clear for people so common
question that i get are as i'm sure
you'll be aware most recruitment
agencies in the uk
are at the size of what you're at right
before previously in terms of like
around 10 people right
so let's just say i'm someone that owns
that business and i i do want to grow
but i am yoyoing all the time
um i'm not sure what this next step is
as i said in the intro you're 16 people
now and i know as you said offline like
you're in a position to grow that even
more it's just obviously getting the
people
like
if i'm listening to this right now what
like what things do i need to sort of
start immediately look at looking at and
maybe taking action on that could give
me put me in good stead to like go from
ten to fifteen fifteen to twenty yeah
that you've done
you think i think
the best thing i ever did from a
structural point of view is write out
where your
prospective heads would go so okay for
example when i was at 10 heads and i'm
sure people are i was like i don't even
know how these people get to 100 heads
get an org chart and write down exactly
what markets what specialisms what areas
of the country you would put people into
or internationally if it's international
because when i did that i realized i
didn't have enough divisions and enough
niches in order to be able to create
enough head count that was the number
one thing that i did and that just
visually gives me something to i'm a
visual person to look at a structure and
go wow you could get to 50 heads here
with all these different markets that
was one
the second thing which i think was um
quite important was build your
infrastructure as if you're going to be
a hundred person business
so at the minute i've built our
infrastructure as if we're going to be
50 heads and therefore you put yourself
under a little bit of pressure when you
start buying source breaker and all
these different tools you think
we are set up now to be able to be 50 60
70 heads everything's set up now we've
got an fd we've got finance we've got it
all of itself
but i think what people do and i did is
you start to hire people before you're
ready and then nothing's in place your
induction's not working nothing's
actually there so i think for us it was
about getting ready before we started to
hire people um and then the third thing
is
you've just got to trust in in yourself
and have the confidence to do it because
10 is a really comfy amount where you're
making good numbers and you're making
good money as you start to break through
15 heads your profit margin does erode
slightly
yeah
something will expect that like you said
like what you've done right you've
invested to grow more right rather than
make more money to take more money
for yourself from whatever you're doing
my bet
but go back to that that thing that we
said about understand what you're trying
to achieve because if you're just trying
to achieve a profit based business
don't grow like stay at 10 12 30 and
just be extreme
yeah yeah you can make loads of money
out of doing that but you do want to
grow you've got to sacrifice it's the
same as anything and the sacrifice is
typically the owner's profit and like if
if that's the case then
the money that i take home is a lot less
than it was but
yes it's because i know what i'm i'm
aiming towards now yeah no
brilliant
before we finish then i have to ask you
because you've been really open on this
i wanted to i guess just just really ask
a question or try and
uncover it a
bit you said a few times obviously early
on
mentally or stressful
you said obviously at that period where
you had a reset you invested in yourself
as well as the business
just i guess what what things have
helped you mentally like get through
things i know you said obviously before
we started like obviously thinking about
the dark days and stuff like that so get
just curious like again like you said
like as the owner sometimes you put that
pressure on yourself to show a brave
face
like people wouldn't have known how
james actually felt about the
environment that he's he's built
or that you weren't satisfied or
fulfilled
yeah i guess she's talked to us about
that process of like commenting terms
with that and then
i guess
yeah maybe just talk a bit about because
people might be feeling like that and so
there might be some things in there that
could help people
move forward or take a step in the right
direction that could help them mentally
yeah i mean if you're a business owner
out there and you've not had investment
and you've got no non-executive director
the world can be quite dark place at
times i mean you're constantly thinking
about next month's bills vat tax these
things and
it can weigh you down a little bit and
just your thought processes can can
start getting slightly warped around
there's a lot of things to think about
and a lot of moving parts um i think the
thing that really helped me recently and
helped me at that period was having a
business partner great understanding guy
we talked a lot he was really supportive
and we were supportive of each other so
that was great when i've lost the
business partner i've had to plug that
in with some external help so i've got a
good network of people um you sell like
everyone in the network that i have now
you could lean on people for advice but
having a personal coach has been the
best thing that i could have ever done
in terms of just it's like having a
sparring partner right you let your
frustrations any and you can vent about
how you're feeling about stuff and
i think there's a bit of a stigma
especially with blokes and and other
business owners that i know
this macho you've got to be looking like
you're successful at all times is key
but it's not actually and i think the
more that people get in tune with how
they're feeling the better it becomes
and i'm the happiest version of myself
that i've been in as long as i can
remember for the last two years and i'd
i'd say that's because i've built the
business that i now want and the
business is doing well and
i'm enjoying the journey of building and
the process of that i love that what
about is it has it been doing going on
that journey does it help you personally
as well and your personal relationships
out of interest
yeah definitely and your personal
relationships are the ones that get hit
the hardest when you grow your business
right because you know my mates are like
like is this guy even still around
because i was just nowhere to be seen i
was working working working working for
the first three years and i've managed
to get some balance now and i think
productivity now has become the key word
for me is you know if i'm sat here just
to show that i'm in the office for 12
hours i'm doing something wrong like my
hours are literally blocked out i'm a
master planner and i make sure that our
team now aren't sitting in the office at
six seven eight o'clock at night anymore
how did you um before we finish how did
you go about finding a personal coach
because that isn't something that maybe
a lot of people have done uh honestly it
was network um so someone recommended a
guy to me that they used and
i ended up um having a first session and
we just got on and it's and it's
snowballed from there really but i've
also started some business coaching
recently which they're very different
processes the personal coaching is just
around mindset really whereas the
business coach is just around
benchmarking ideas and making sure that
you're not going to go down the wrong
path i think the biggest problem when
growing a recruitment business is you go
down a lot of rabbit warrens that
don't come to anything and then you have
to reverse out of it and it might take
you six 12 months to realize you've made
a mistake
so yeah i love that and then just just
find a curious like what do these
sessions actually look like is it just
like are they asking you questions i
don't know just just to paint a picture
for people
the personal ones or the business either
yeah just to give us a bit of a snapshot
so the the personal ones are generally
sort of talking about
um how your week's been like i mean to
start off with like what you're trying
to achieve like you would with any sort
of session and then when you transition
into the day-to-day of it it's just
how's your week been what's been the
challenges how have you overcome them
have you felt about them
and it really just the way i describe it
is it untangles your brain yeah you've
got a thousand tabs open in your head it
allows you to close 900 of them
i love that and then
and then the business coach there's just
more business context and a bit more
business professional chat
the thing with the business court um and
and it sounds like overkill on coaching
it's not it's an hour sometimes an hour
a month in some of these things but it's
someone to keep you accountable to do
the things that you know you need to do
that you don't want to do yeah and you
haven't got a business partner who
probably
helps with that right that he absolutely
so it's like what do you actually need
to do and we created these three key
principles and it's sort of right what
are the projects that are going to spin
out of that well we need to put a
an aj playbook together on sales okay
that's not something that i'm going to
sit there and do unless someone makes me
accountable for it i know but i know
it's important but i'm just not i'm not
going to sit and do it unless i know
there's a benefit to me and so it's just
like oh that date's coming around again
i better get some of this work done
anyways yeah it keeps keeps me
accountable for what i'm doing i love
that
and then final thing i know we said i
was an architect i know a lot of people
will get value from it
um obviously i saw not too long ago you
had
multiple people become shareholders in
aj that must have been a proud moment
for you
yeah
could you just talk to us before we
finish just a bit about
i guess how you structured that
like i don't know just tell us because i
feel like a lot of um conversation had
recently valency leaders is like they
like for those that do want to grow and
maybe achieve some sort of event or they
are thinking
like how they could sort of get in the
position where they're like very much
maybe become a chairman of their own
business and other people were involved
like could you tell us a bit about how
that structured and how these people
could yeah how that works
yeah yeah so um
effectively i used to want 100 of the
business i've i've dissolved some of my
equity to give it out to our leadership
team currently but the plan is to give
it out to the wider team so i've put
that equity in a pot for the leaders of
our business
and i've divvied that up and said look
these are the divisions that you run
this is where we want to get to from a
target perspective as a business i'm
going to give you this equity today and
then you can grow that equity in our
business over a course of three to five
years love that that was the first thing
um and that's not um just to for clarity
that's twofold we've got an emi scheme
for staff so that they can own shares in
our business and this is equity so i'm
basically giving out yeah yeah it's
different so um and it's important for
me that i bring people on the journey
with me that i'm not just this person
that takes text text x takes and i've
become less money motivated as the years
go on and it's all about building this
sustainable business now
and so you know i brought obviously
steph our first ever employee started as
a senior consultant now runs her own
business unit and she's got equity
rick and marcus
rick are brought in from oliver james
two years ago he now warns a good size
of the business and runs our sales
function and marcus who came in recently
is going to be
in charge of our exec search practice
and so i've got the three pillars of my
business now that i'm going to build out
people through
and then people like alicia that you've
met
um
he's on a trajectory now to get herself
into a position to get some emi shares
and all the time what i'd like to do is
is that the
the team own half the business i love
that
yeah anyone that's like thinking about
that i'm sure you'll be happy to get in
touch with you
yeah i think and i guess to wrap this up
like how
what being the positives that have come
out that so far i feel like that would
be such an uplifting
like optimistic thing to have given to
you or the opportunity how what's been
the impact so far do you think
from your point of view
yeah the impact's been great uh however
like to go back a step i've
not given that out as an incentive
necessarily it's twofold i've given it
out as a reward for real hard work and
dedication but i've also it's
incentivizing them for the future but
the thing is there's nothing better
right than feeling like you've got the
ability to all part of a business so
there's no one sat out on our sales for
today that can't have that same
situation happen to them and that's
important to me because
um i got given the opportunity early on
and i i've taken my opportunity but i
want to be able to share that success i
think the positive thing is is that it's
really really glued our culture together
yeah if it needed doing but it just
feels like everyone's on the bus in our
business yeah and everyone's like you
said you've never done what that purpose
is and
yeah people can really see that and
they're all going in that same
trajectory yeah
and also it's given real accountability
through the structure of our business
now that i don't run any part of our
business i just help the guys with what
they need so if steph needs me i'm
around and i do a lot around the podcast
now for for our client base etc but my
my role now is just to outwardly present
aj and i've become a recruitment
internal recruiter you know i'm just
recruiting people for our team though
james been an absolute pleasure thanks
for being super open honest
glorious really enjoyed that thanks a
lot
cheers thank you